Trump has security throw out a Univision
reporter Jorge Ramos I think for asking
him a question out of turn it got real
weird real fast here's a clip
excuse me sit down you weren't called
sit down sit down sit down
you haven't been called go back to
Univision I don't know really much about
him I don't believe I've ever met him
except he started screaming and I would
I didn't ask or him out yeah I don't
know it yeah I mean didn't that seem
like a bit of an overreaction on that
part he wasn't screaming yeah of course
the reporter was not screaming not at
all I don't think any no it's my phone
hold on a second Yello
go that it's got a truck
it's not a Trump everybody yes sir I can
hear you
let it go tit first of all your might a
lot that's funny
number two you're dead wrong about the
press conference okay but how did you
know that we were even talking about
this shut up and sit out to sit out sir
I am sitting down sit lower if you're
doing me good lower I don't think I
consider lever on your chair reach down
lower your carefree very low mr. Trump
I'm sorry but it did sound like you were
a little disrespectful to mr. Ramos stop
yelling okay you're screaming at the
coated it's not professional no I'm not
screaming at you sir
use your indoor voice Tony it sounds
nuts listen that Latino reporter was a
madman it was like a motorized big yacht
full of hot sauce mr. Trump you can't
say that no liquid I'm telling you coded
Speedy Gonzales read right at me look
those are all offensive stereotypes sir
hold on hold on hold on stop talking my
assistant just brought me a printout of
more stereotypes okay Toto having it how
do you pronounce that sweeter quite the
Dilla
was it quick okay today mr. Tom after
yesterday people are once again
wondering how you as president of the
United States would handle diplomacy
with foreign leaders malicious that's a
piece of cake step one I'll send them
all chairs Trump chairs they're fabulous
chairs step to the other does sit out
and shut up yes siree if they're still
standing I'll send my security guy you
saw them is huge to kick them off step 4
America is great again hey no wait a
minute that's that's ridiculous
okay look what Larry get in there get
coated out of there
get it go away this is my show you can't
[Applause]